[Music]
don't forget to enter our Amazon
giftcard giveaway all you have to do is
like the video and comment hey guys the
fourth episode of the final season just
ended and wow I'm still in shock it was
a pretty good episode overall it was a
build up episode for the last war the
battle for the iron throne that comes in
episode 5 directed by miguel suppo
connect and that's and the things will
actually go down then I lost almost
everything in a span of two episodes
firstly Jericho no and most of our
armies in a fight against the night king
and now before the battle against earth
even started she's already lost her
Dragon regal then he also lost [ __ ] her
mostly will advisors and friends miss
sandy that's been with her almost from
the very beginning and on top of that
she's lost her in the most game eternal
style way possible so brutal and unjust
death all I want now is vengeance sir
save of the dragon and she'll suffer the
consequences in episode 5 fire and blood
lady Olenna Tyrell was right back in
season 7 when she said to Danny be a
dragon she'll finally be won in episode
5 Danny has lost almost everything and
if Cersei thinks she's saved just
because she invited citizens inside red
keep she is up for a big surprise
and honestly what was that earrings look
after Mustaine is beheading he was like
don't stake home
don't kill my sister don't attack the
red key even though she's literally
killing me saying in front of them and
then he's left with no choice
I can guarantee you then Indian solid
will go on an execution spring King's
Landing and I think that will be exactly
what Cersei bonad if search they did not
want to attack in laning and red cape
Cersei would not be stupid enough to
behead me sandy Cersei wants Danny to
attack and we'll find out why exactly in
the upcoming episode
perhaps she has one more trick up in her
sleeve I think sir snake has worked out
this entire plane in her head and will
now watch it play out perhaps she wants
then it only Shogun and start burning
King's Landing
bringing surfs opportunity to use many
khyber scorpions to bring her last icon
down and then use the golden company
Lannisters and US forces to deal with
the remains of dennis for
or perhaps she intends to get them all
fighting inside a capital and then burn
them all with one fire one way or
another sir says face expression she
gives Daniel killing sin is basically
telling your moon now anyways let's get
back to the beginning the episode
expectedly opens up a manifold where we
see the ruins of the aftermath of the
Battle of Winterfell
everyone is tired but before they can
rest they need to burn the dead and pay
their respects to those many who were
lost including theme gradually in danger
moments buried no Darian Edco no and
many more then it's got her final moment
vajura kissing him on forehead as a
final farewell to her most loyal protect
her here we see the mass funeral pyres
with the surviving characters in
attendance from left to right the
torchbearer sort o moon John's saying
sorry a grave warm Danny and Sam also
present our John Royce Davos Seaworth
brain ghost various myths and debris and
Tyrion and Jaime as a dad burned the
sink as to the celebration Dany
legitimizes ginjury and makes him Lord
of storms end he's the last with
Baratheon blood and his support brings
through more power and more fighting men
this proves once again that then it does
not hold children guilty of their
father's crimes and doings
King Robert thought Rhaegar kidnapped
and raped Liana so he went into
rebellion had every Targaryen killed and
even attempted to have his assassins
killed Annie and her unborn child and
then he could have done the same she
could have said to ganger your father
you served my family almost killed all
of us and exiled us everywhere our Theon
I get my handsome will die but she
didn't say any much like John doesn't
hold children guilty of their fathers
doings and I actually predicted again
you will get legitimized in one of my
games videos I said that if Daniel al
Tyrion to become her most trusted
advisor whose father did more crimes to
House Targaryen than Robert dead I don't
see my daddy would knowledge in my skin
jury if he would bend the knee and swear
his loyalty to her anyways then we have
ginjury arya seen he asked her to marry
him
he has her to be his wife the lady of
storms end but she says no that's not me
the reason behind this no is because she
has some unfinished business and it will
not be before then that already decides
to settle down this is confirmed by some
official teases missive Illium said this
for our story for season 8
there's this split vitória between
trying to be who she wants to be getting
back to back to that naivete and
innocence with her family and her
unfinished business areas got to finish
one last mission shut the green eyes
search his eyes and she will be
accompanied by the hound on that mission
Rory McCann who plays the hound also
hinted at this so he gave us a hint at a
confrontation between the hound and the
mountain by saying there will be a
chance of screwing up to his brother and
facing those demons still Gangi gets his
last moment with Aria a bit luckier than
ginjuries Jamie who finally sees that
Brienne is the right woman for him the
one who brings the best out of him
Tyrion Paul Brienne and Jaime play a
game the same game team played in
earlier seasons is brown and shine tear
in his brain if she's a virgin and then
she leaves turmond also comes over to
them but that Jaime gets in the way and
falls brain and the tool finally make
love one just has to be happy to see
these two together although also a bit
said for torment I'm sure he'll find
himself some mother big woman now that
he settles in the North since and the
Hound finally shared the scene together
Sensa tells him how she fell ramsay to
the hounds the count says you've changed
a little bird the same nickname he's
been calling her since season one before
we leave Winterfell for Dragonstone in
King's Landing plans are being made for
attack on King's Landing Tyrion and
other consultants weren't any not too
harsh on King's Landing she doesn't
listen John is apprehensive and says
someone's in order to stop fighting
altogether after what they've been
through then it's oh how John was loved
by the people so later she goes to his
chambers and they talk she wishes she
didn't tolerate cetera and then John
said he will tell the truth to his
family even though then it doesn't want
anyone to know or incense I got told at
God's hood with brain this poor Jon over
Danny because she is not one of them the
pack sticks together since a later told
the secret to Tyrion and he told Varys
Tyrion and Varys seemingly believe Jon
would make a better King as well even
though Tyrion does say they would rule
together it seems they believe Dan is
becoming the meth Queen where is reminds
Tyrion that his loyalty stands with the
people reminding him that if he sees
better fit ruler he is going to side
with that one and it seems that Varys
whole switch sides and choose John a
more a more Stern the two will make
their best
is John rather than Danny who gets the
aren't room it sucks a bit because Danny
really trusted Tyrion and believed him
to be her most trusted advisor also
Braun finally appears he reveals the
Lancer brothers that he's come to
assassinate them on Cersei's orders but
of course he's not doing it because
remember whatever they are paying him
Tyrion will always pay Dumble after all
brawn lies the Wayans brothers much more
than he likes the Queen and initially
brunt doesn't really need money anymore
as he said to Jamie in season seven he's
got plenty of gold but all he doesn't
have any girl he wants is a promise
Castle on the high bone beautiful wife
Cersei could secure him all of that but
bran is smart enough to realize Cersei
cannot win this war at the end bran was
offered Highgarden by Tyrion a bit later
most of the main characters live in FL
except census same giving torment for
staying far front war in the North
taking into account this is worth
dwelling story arch led by tone intense
I'm a bit sad that ghost goes with
torment on Jon's request this means that
it's probably the last we've seen of
ghost Jamie's going south as well but he
has seemingly betrayed Danny in the
Starks bring cried when he lands and
before they told him all the bad things
he has done or would've done as
Targaryen fleet travels from white
Harbor to Dragonstone with Danny riding
dragon accompanied by regal urines fleet
launches a surprise attack on their
fleet the outcome recall killed by urine
who seemingly did not miss a shot it is
scorpion a Mustaine days captured her on
killing Raghava the scorpion is probably
aesthetically appealing rewrite of your
killing dragons with a horn in the books
at King's Landing Cersei invites all to
small fold to hide behind their walls
earning their loyalty when in reality
she's inviting them inside to use them
as a shield from Danny energy Agins
a jagged stone after a girl has just
been killed and missing a kidnapped then
have it realized and advisors discusses
what to do next they decide to go to the
capital to negotiate with Cersei my ago
she Asians are done with and Cersei
orders the mountain to behead me sandy
if I'm being honest such brutal and
unjust death in Game of Thrones has not
been seen for a very long time since the
red wedding I'd say when I also notice
kit harington an actor who plays Jon
Snow talking about in his recent
interview one of my favorite episodes
is for because the characters have
seemingly got what they needed the world
is safe now they are celebrating and
saying goodbye to lost friends but as an
audience you're going this is only
episode four something's going to happen
and that's the cool thing because I
think the characters are aware of this
as well there's something twisted and
uncomfortable about it it's so
Shakespearean one just got to feel bad
for Danny and specially for a grey worm
then again ever since and a grey born
playing their future earlier on in the
season about how they would go to
missing his homeland and how he will
protect her there it was pretty much
confirmed one of them was going to die
and it was going to be a great worm in
the Battle of Winterfell or me sandy and
now we know missandei of Nath with good
heart was loyal to her Queen to the
bitter end
her death marks the beginning of the
Battle of King's Landing
the Battle of the our town I can
guarantee Kree warm in his on solid will
go nuts after this and so will Danny
they will only show they have on Cersei
but unfortunately as I said in the
beginning of this video I think that's
exactly what Cersei bone it but look she
gives them it just feels like she wants
them to attack right there and right now
perhaps she wants they need to bring her
lash dragon so they could shoot him down
as well or perhaps she wants them to
strong King's Landing so she could use
wildfire to burn them all episode 5 the
Battle of King's Landing is going to be
one big epic battle episode and by the
end of it we'll know who won the game of
Thrones will know who survives and who
doesn't
this is the last war there are so many
leaked photos and so much information we
know about episode 5 and the Battle of
King's Landing but obviously this is
episode 4 breakdown and so will not talk
about those Polar's here video regarding
everything we know about episode 5 is
currently making and will be published
as soon as possible all I'm going to say
here is that the backlash will be insane
stay tuned for that my next video in
which I'm bringing some bare of King's
Landing Lee photos where you can see how
there is fire and blood will look like
as well as how King's Landing will look
like after it's all done in order please
let me know your thoughts about all of
this in the comment section down below
also let me know your thoughts about
episode 4 did you like it or not and why
and as always I hope you guys enjoyed
this video if you did please make sure
to subscribe to our Channel and I hope
to see you in the next one